la sentencia llegó la expresidenta de
transición de bolivia jeanine áñez
escuchó virtualmente su condena a 10
años de prisión por actos contra la
constitución junto a dos jefes militares
y policiales condenándolos a la pena
privativa de libertad de diez años a
cumplir en el centro penitenciario de
san pedros de la ciudad de la paz tienen
centros de orientación femenina de
miraflores respectivamente a partir de
la fecha hasta el 10 de junio de 2032
la expresidenta fue juzgada por sus
actos como senadora antes de asumir la
presidencia en noviembre de 2019 en ese
momento los opositores denunciaron a evo
morales- de cometer un fraude electoral
para conseguir su cuarto mandato
consecutivo hasta 2025 años que era
senadora de oposición asumió el poder
luego de que el ejército obligará a
renunciar a moral es un acto utilizado
por el oficialismo como un golpe de
estado como presidenta áñez encaró las
protestas de movimientos sociales y
campesinos afines a morales que
terminaron con más de 30 fallecidos
según la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos
su mandato transitorio se extendió por
la llegada del cob y 19 el juicio contra
la abogada que lleva más de un año
impresión mostró la polarización que se
vive en el país
y legal de principio a fin mi madre
nunca se autoproclamó están jugando de
manera arbitraria y puede no estar de
pie pedimos justicia justicia que llega
a 30 años de cárcel para gianni de años
y sus secuaces
la defensa ha dicho que apelará a la
decisión que consideran una persecución
política y que acudirá a la justicia
internacional